[Music]
foreign
looking to get a better understanding of
how your trained models are making
decisions with the help of vertex
explainable AI you can better understand
explain and interpret your model's
outputs and predictions hi I'm Chloe
Condon a developer advocate for Google
cloud and in this video I'm going to
give you an overview of vertex Ai and
show you how vertex explainable AI can
help you better understand your model's
outputs for classification and
regression tasks let's get started
to better understand vertex explainable
AI let's quickly cover what vertex AI is
and how it works
vertex AI is Google Cloud's end-to-end
machine learning platform that helps
engineers and data scientists accelerate
machine learning experimentation and
deployment
it brings together Google Cloud's
existing ml offerings into a single
environment for efficiently building and
managing the life cycle of ml projects
in one single place you can import and
label your data and train evaluate and
deploy your model once the model is
deployed vertex AI allows you to get
your predictions using either command
line interface console AI or the SDK or
apis
explainable AI comes into play in the
model training and evaluation steps of
the process
when assessing explanations we want to
know what factors play a role in
defining the predictions that have been
provided that's where example-based
explanations and feature attributions
come into play
let's take for example a machine
learning model that predicts whether a
coffee shop is open or not with feature
attributions you could get an
explanation like the coffee shop is not
open because the door is locked in this
scenario the coffee shop is a feature
and the closed door is an attribute of
that feature with explainable AI example
based or similarity explanations provide
us with more context and secondary
information to help explain and
emphasize the differences in our data
and explain how the model Acts
for example here are 10 other coffee
shops that are closed and the doors are
also locked
this includes more context and secondary
information for us to better understand
differences in our data set and or how
the model is acting since vertex AI is
able to tell us how much each feature
contributed to the predicted result with
feature attribution as well as find
similar examples from example based we
can then use this information to verify
that the model is behaving as expected
recognize bias in your models and get
ideas for how to improve your model and
training your data keep an eye out for
future videos where we dive deeper into
feature attribution and example-based
explanations
understanding how machine learning
models make predictions and being able
to communicate those insights to
external stakeholders and other people
within your organization is a key part
of being able to properly evaluate and
interpret your machine learning models
having clear and accurate explanations
for models can help several groups
within your organization be it your
model Builders data scientists and ml
Ops who want to better understand why
their model isn't performing or how to
improve it
end users of machine learning systems
are looking to see if they can trust the
model or make decisions on how to
respond to the prediction
or public stakeholders within or outside
your organization who may be involved in
regulatory or compliance with your
machine learning models
they can use explanations to make sure
models are safe to use and help develop
guidance for Industries on responsible
use of AI
the insights provided by vertex
explainable AI can be used to figure out
exactly why or how these models came to
specific conclusions and help you
evaluate your ml model's predictions
in this video we talked about vertex Ai
and how explainable AI provides us with
the tools needed to better interpret
your model's predictions in our next
video we'll dive a little deeper and go
over some examples of how you can use
custom Frameworks to analyze models in
the meantime if you'd like to get
started you can go to the explainable AI
documentation Linked In the description
or scan the QR code on the screen for
more information and step-by-step guides
thanks for tuning in
[Music]